[Music]
hey guys and welcome to a very special
episode of congratulations
[Music]
hell yeah what's up guys
it's crystalia and here we are with the
something uh 200 something episode of
congratulations and it's live and it's
on and popping baby and i don't mean
it's actually live i just mean like i'm
very live like i had my two ice
americanos i had one this time from
earth cafe
and uh i got it here with the green
straw the straw is too thin but it's all
good i need to have a coffee channel is
what i need to do you know how like that
guy dave portnoy does the [ __ ]
one-bite pizza i need a one-sip coffee
dude i should [ __ ] do that dude that
is a good idea
why don't i do that come on
[ __ ] let's do this [ __ ] um one
sip coffee that's what i'll do i'll go
to different places you'll find me in
[ __ ] different places dude
i mean you'll find me in [ __ ] i'll go
to what would you call it uh omaha and
just sip i'll go to omaha for one sip
dude
nobody's ever done that in the world man
that's some japanese [ __ ] some some
japanese dude would do that
just to go somewhere for one sip that's
so [ __ ] poetic a japanese that was
just japanese and [ __ ] to go to [ __ ]
somewhere for one sip uh you had to fly
to a
hotep of a coffee
super racist to do that voice but
whatever man it's 2022 nothing's
changing anytime soon
and uh i'm not racist so we're all good
but i did the voice and maybe you think
it is racist but whatever dude we do
voices you know um
i'm gonna be in different cities
not doing the one sip them thing you
know maybe further on down the line but
i'm doing the cities
for my tour chrisleya.com for my tour
uh that's what's up i got a bunch of
different places coming up
um i'm going to atlanta i'm going to dc
i'm going to boston
i'm going to jacksonville florida this
is is this your are these your places
dude
uh stockton oakland california atlanta
september 9th is going to be frink and
liddy oh i'm also doing the hollywood
california improv may 25th that's just
for fun crystalia and friends keeping it
liddy peoria keeping it liddy rockford
illinois keeping it liddy
uh raleigh north carolina keeping it
super litty um
savannah georgia lydia's [ __ ] denver
colorado november 5th get your tickets
at crystallia.com cheyenne wyoming
boston massachusetts november 12th
almost sold out jacksonville florida
december 3rd keeping it absolutely frank
and liddy so this tour is uh is bonkers
dude and we're going and we're doing it
all and that's how we and that's how we
do it i got this i got the reflecting
uh
uh sunglasses on right now taking them
off but i like the reflecting ones
because when you talk to me you see you
when you talk to me you see you dude and
so that's what's up so if you're talking
[ __ ]
when you're looking at me you're talking
[ __ ] secretly to yourself if you look
closely rack focus then when you talk
[ __ ] rack focus when i've got the
reflectos on rack focus who are we
really talking to you're talking to
yourself dude
that's it man
oh [ __ ] dude you must hate yourself me
and the reflectors me and the [ __ ]
reflect those oh you must really hate
yourself
that's me dude um so anyway i'm sipping
real nice on the thin green straw from
earth cafe and uh
the thin green straw
by ridley scott
with francis mcdormand
the thin green straw
a woman wandering around
trying to recycle
the thin green straw
anyway dude that's where i'm gonna be
keeping it litty boston's almost sold
out the boston babies come out dude it's
like i'm running around with a [ __ ]
bunch of beans in my pockets dude what
the [ __ ]
uh so yeah man we're flying by the seat
of our pants and uh if you want to go
see michael linoche he's a very funny
comedian irvine improv he's going to be
may 26 and reno of nevada june 2nd
he [ __ ] opens for me sometimes and
the guy's really funny i told him i plug
his dates i'm a nice friend
what can you say
so yeah we got merch also on
crystalia.com get that merch for the
[ __ ] shows we got that don't push me
[ __ ] we got that um
uh oops [ __ ] i keep meaning to wear the
[ __ ]
i'm on the podcast the oops merch but i
don't do it the guy got the gallery
department [ __ ] on right now this shirt
costs way just a pretty penny and it's
just some regular fabric dude
it's just some regular fabric man people
just be buying that [ __ ] because it's on
a billboard and some chicks just on the
billboard it's not even for women and
they're they're it's like ferment it's
like says gallery department for man or
some [ __ ] and there's a woman on the
billboard just like this
and you're just like all right dude i
guess i gotta buy it man they got me a
hook line and sinker dude
they got me didn't they man i saw
[ __ ] jay-z in a music video wearing
[ __ ] gallery department they got me
dude
they [ __ ] got me immediately
so i got the neon green one and then i
put it in the wash and it faded a little
bit because it's just some regular
fabric yeah maybe i put it with the
wrong shits
maybe i put it with the wrong shits but
i did it
i went to the bank you know the other
day just to [ __ ] deposit some funds
right
because i asked for checks at my gigs
wire the money it doesn't feel real
right
right it doesn't feel real if you wire
the money so i get to check and i travel
to the bank that's like one of my chores
dude because i want to feel like a real
person i want to have the money in hand
i don't want to [ __ ] deposit it in
hand dude so your buddy takes racks
brings it to the bank [ __ ] gives it
to them like a real person and i'm there
and this guy comes in dude there should
be a game show in los angeles called
homeless or trendy that's honestly what
the [ __ ] game show should be the guy
comes in and i go like this this guy
is either
like gonna drop [ __ ] stacks here he's
either gonna [ __ ] like he's either
walking in like my phone is heavy from
all the amount of money i've been
depositing in it even virtually
digitally it's still my phone's heavy
from the from the digital money
or they're gonna ask him to leave i have
no [ __ ] idea if this guy's worth 8
billion dollars or zero billion dollars
i have no idea the guy comes in
and he's like kind of you know he's
either limping or walking cool
and he says to the guy who who's there
like the manager or something you got an
outside line so now i'm like i don't
even know even more right because he's
either homeless and crazy or
entitled
right he's like you got an outside line
and guess what not only do i not know
this the [ __ ] manager at the bank
doesn't know it right so he's like oh
god i don't know if he's a customer or
not and i don't want to [ __ ] throw a
guy out and then you know it's all over
the news i throw out a [ __ ] 8 billion
hedge fund dude
so the guy's like look we got plenty of
phones obviously he says yeah we got one
over here and he goes like that and the
guy goes oh can i use it he says um um
sure i'm sure
when i was a [ __ ] when i was in high
school i went with my friend brandon
goody and we went to the shoe place to
buy some shoes and this guy was so
nervous man he looked like at night
shyamalan and he was at the [ __ ]
place and he owned the shoe store or no
he was just the worker the shoe store i
don't know but he looked like m night
shyamalan this was before m night
shyamalan was popping this was before
right back when m night shyamalan was
just known for making stuart little
right there was no
are you dead yet [ __ ] movie or
whatever it's called
[Laughter]
are you dead yet like it's with [ __ ]
ice cube
are you dead yet
it's like a like it's a family comedy
with ice cube
from the makers of
how the [ __ ] is ice cube in family
movies by the way
straight outta compton [ __ ]
[ __ ] named ice cube and like 15
later he's like did y'all pack lunches
did you eat your [ __ ] did you eat your
breakfast boys
from [ __ ] the police
do you like your eggs sunny side up
in just 11 years um and i was at the
[ __ ] uh shoe place with my buddy and
my and and the and he was so nervous
and the end we were and we were like
every shoe we asked he was like do you
have these in a 13 and he would always
say actually um we we used to have these
okay
[Laughter]
dude he did it three times and we're
like okay i guess we're just gonna go
dude imagine having a store and you go
in and you have to say that three times
to somebody actually you know what we
used to have these but we don't have
them anymore and we don't have them in
your size and we left and me and brenda
were like what the [ __ ] dude
how many times we actually used to have
them and dude we don't do that and i
think about that all the time we
actually we used to have them and so
that guy was so nervous telling us that
he didn't have the shoes and it made me
think of the guy in the bank that was
like do you have an outside line he was
like actually i already actually used to
have one but now we use cell phones and
so anyway he was in the uh
back he was like sure you could use this
one and he goes like and he says and bro
the conversation i couldn't even believe
it
the guy was like okay cool and then the
the guy picks up the phone and then the
the banker guy he was like
okay um you just gotta hit
nine first and like we all know this
conversation right when you're out of
work you gotta hit nine first
sometimes you got to be reminded for
right you go you start to die like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] one eight oh two you
know you do the [ __ ] one eight one
eight whatever the three two three
and you and then it goes and you're like
what the [ __ ] you don't hear anything
you're like oh whoops i'm i'm a piece of
[ __ ] today i i was i haven't
used a phone in 30 years because this is
what has been happening in businesses
for the past 30 years and i didn't dial
to get an outside line right
and you say do it and then like an
[ __ ] you'll be like do i have to hit
something first when you know you just
hit nine
you they're never like yeah hit four
it's always nine
so you're a big piece of [ __ ] but
sometimes you forget and sometimes it's
okay right and if you're a homeless
person or a billionaire you might be so
out of touch on either end of the
spectrum that you're like you know what
i don't know how to hit the chits i just
work with my cell phone
so the guy's like
picks up the thing and then the banker
preempts that conversation and he says
you have to hit nine first to get an
outside line
and the guy says
and then and then just and then what
and the banker guys like
just no well that's it just hit nine
and then just whatever you're gonna dial
to get the number
and the guy says so then hit one or
or don't hit one
and he says well it just if if it's
if it's the number that you're gonna
dial
just you gotta hit the area code and
then the guy says so just the area code
and he says well no you hit nine just to
get the outside line and he says right
and then i just hit the area code
and this is so loud dude and there's
literally like six people in the bank
and he's like so just hit nine then
you'll hit whatever it is you need to
use and the guy says
so nine and then one and then
and then whatever area code the guy says
and i'm and i'm looking at the thing
like this i'm literally like this
and everyone is look it was one of those
moments where something weird is
happening in an establishment
and everyone then knows each other you
know
like one time a guy came into the
[ __ ] coffee bean i used to run over
on cold water i mean i used to be the
[ __ ] sultan of the coffee bean and
tea leaf i used to be the [ __ ] bean
czar at coffee bean and tea leaf over on
cold water and ventura they don't have
it anymore right but i used to be the
[ __ ] bean czar over there
and uh
i mean i used to come home [ __ ]
stinking like colombian beans you know i
used to come home and it used to be like
i was having an affair with some [ __ ]
brazilian with a brazilian roast
honey where were you nothing i what is
this it you smell
you smell like south of the border
i know i was at the
were you rubbing beans on your [ __ ]
and so i was the beans are so i was
there all the time
and uh were you rubbing
show me show me your let me smell your
dick remember that song let me smell
your dick
she's just
i smell a light roast
i'm leaving gunk
oh come on baby
so um
i smell pike drip
baby gunk
[Music]
[ __ ]
um so
yeah so i was at a i was at that place
and this dude comes in and immediately
he's like oh dude i love your stuff man
and i was like oh cool but he was too
loud and i was like oh thanks a lot he
was like yeah man saw you at the laugh
factory once and yada yada this and that
and he was like do you know you know do
you know the owner of the lab factory i
was like yeah jamie masada was like oh
man i know him man i see him all the
time and i'm like okay well he's lying
you know he gets his coffee he gets four
[ __ ] of those frappy drinks you know
at the coffee bean and he gets he has
the cases and he goes to leave the
[ __ ] coffee bean and as he leaves
he's like dude you know what we should
we should kick it sometimes hit me up
hit me up on instagram let's kick it
sometimes and then he as he's kicking
the door open because he's holding the
[ __ ] tray of the coffees he says
strictly hetero and [ __ ] leaves dude
and that's what he said and i will never
forget that [ __ ] he said strictly hetero
kicked the door and [ __ ] walked out
with the [ __ ] fraps dude and everyone
looked at me and i was like it doesn't
sound strictly hetero to me but anyway
we all knew each other dude
this is what happened into the [ __ ]
uh at the coffee bean and tea leaf and
now that's what happened with the
[ __ ]
bank right the guy says what's the
outside line what's the outside line
and then he looks at the [ __ ]
everyone now i know everyone at the bank
is my point but now i'm a different
person right i'm not going to be [ __ ]
sleeping with every anyone at the bank
plus it was always it was just men in
there
so
the guy the bank guy ends up just saying
listen you just hit nine
and then whatever you were gonna hit hit
and then he did it
and that's the end of the [ __ ] story
dude
was that the dog
i'm pissed the dog barked i'm pissed
the dog barks all the time dude and i
[ __ ] hate it
[Music]
i went to the doctor dude
you want to know why
i love you guys man
i went to the doctor
because
dude i woke up
about five days in a row
and honestly
dude my [ __ ] nose
[ __ ] hurt so bad couldn't even
believe it it was like a mack truck
[ __ ] literally drove into my nose and
stayed there and [ __ ] was like and
peeled out and left
[Applause]
[ __ ] yeah dude my nose hurts every time
i wake up
yes man [ __ ] yeah dude
so i said i talked about it i never want
to go to the doctor you know it's so
annoying you gotta park and [ __ ]
and wait and then you gotta talk to like
nine people before you talk to the
doctor it's like dude just
can i go to the can i just you know hi
fill this how they're always like how
long have you been when have you changed
your insurance and you're like dude
what am i mr know-it-all i don't know if
i changed my [ __ ] insurance
they're like did you have any changes of
the and you're like when's the last time
i was here and they're always like april
of 2002 and you're like
yeah there's been some changes
you gotta park and then [ __ ]
so i complained about it too much and
then kristen was like okay i made you an
appointment and i'm like [ __ ] great
now i gotta go and she was like but it's
good because your nose is all [ __ ] up
anyway and you know that because when
you look up your nose is bent to all get
out it is dude if i if you catch me
under me
my [ __ ] is just bent
and um
[Music]
and so uh
well every time i say ben i think of
this guy that [ __ ] dressed up like
tupac once this white dude that dressed
up like tupac once uh this was back when
myspace was a thing and he had a photo
album of his halloween where he dressed
up like tupac and the [ __ ] title of
the album was tupac shabent
because
because he was so drunk
i mean so not a not even [ __ ] didn't
even try to might as well just said
tupac should drunk
um
two bach tupac sh i'm drinking so uh
so anyway uh
i [ __ ] i'm like all right dude she
made an appointment and we both went but
she's like i'll go with you and i'm like
all right cool so we went
we went to this doctor that i you know i
won't say him but he's just [ __ ] done
so many celebrities like singers he's an
ears nose and throat guy
i mean we're talking about like [ __ ]
nile horror end to [ __ ]
uh you know john mayer he did [ __ ]
stevie wonders i mean he probably didn't
do his eyes but he did stevie wonder too
uh oh ears nose and throat that's why
he's probably blind he did work on
stevie wonder if he did his eyes he'd
probably fix him
but dude this guy's like got like go
gold plat like charlie puth you know and
just [ __ ] crate his walls are just
decker even sasha baron cohen is like
thanks for helping me with my [ __ ]
lockjaw or some [ __ ]
and uh and now i'm there dude and i'm
sitting there and there's a [ __ ] big
nickelback poster staring at me all of
them signed it thanks for fixing my
throat doc you know
and for that one you you're like maybe
you shouldn't have fixed it you know
like this guy's literally the reason why
creed can go with arms wide open
and uh so i'm there now because my nose
is dry as [ __ ] and he comes in nice as
[ __ ] doc is great
oh well actually we get there and the
lady's like are there any changes and
i'm like yeah i don't know just here's
my wallet you know she's like do you
haven't i'm just like here's my wallet
just take whatever you need here's a lot
you give i always [ __ ] it up i'm like is
this the insurance
and they're like no that's actually your
[ __ ] library card and i'm like i
still have that you know
and so we we get finally into the
doctor's office dude this is how awesome
and cool the doctor is
i waited an hour and 15 minutes
literally made me wait an hour and 15
minutes an hour and 15 minutes in a
small room with kristen and nickelback
staring at me
dude it was like the weirdest dream and
i'm sitting there and here's the weird
part i wasn't even mad i said to her 15
minutes in i said i wonder how long this
is going to take cause i'm working on a
number two here and she was like go and
i was like yeah but then when he comes
he's gonna go another patient dude i
held it for an hour my bowels were
working with me dude
just staring at nickelback trying to
[ __ ] unbrew a number two
you know what i'm saying
just staring out there staring at the
photograph
unbrewing the number two
and just [ __ ] st just just tr
working on percolating a brown mess
staring at the band fuel
dude
what's that can you no that's uh crete
what's the [ __ ] fuel song
uh
[Music]
in my hair
my hair
that's it dudes the 90s
just percolating a brown mess staring at
fuel staring at fuel signatures saying
thanks for everything just percolating
the brown mess dude
just waiting in that chair just [ __ ]
percolating a brown mess
dude he made me wait so long i figured
the chair out you ever figured the chair
out i i looked at it i go
[Music]
feet two
oh there's my toesies
there they are
never seen my feet before
and i [ __ ] took a nap dude kristen
didn't complain at all she's an angel
dude
an hour and 15 minutes he comes in he
was like sorry i was on the phone with
yada yada i didn't need to tell you all
that [ __ ] but it was all right it was a
good reason
he goes like this let me see inside your
nose i was already back baby
i figured out that he's oh you figured
out the chat i figured out the chair
he go takes the longest this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] i mean
and he just goes
dude it felt like it came out of the
back of my head it just up into my brain
[ __ ] me
just absolutely [ __ ] me up well i had
a singing teacher once and he was trying
to tell me about like accessing uh
singing i used to take singing classes
you know
and he was i used to do a one-on-one uh
man he the guy was the [ __ ] dude and he
talked like this and he was like no you
really want to open your soft palate
like it was like a little bit like mark
wahlberg but one time he was like he was
trying to describe something to me about
memory recall and he was like do you
know if scientists adopt us if they were
to if they would open up your brain and
poke around in your brain
he literally said do you know that if
they were to poke around in your brain
you know he actually said and you know
it's off color but this is what he said
he said besides you know besides you
getting all [ __ ] and stuff like what
would happen is it'll recall it'll
record you'll have memory recall and i
was like jesus even when i was like 19 i
was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know just sitting in a guy's living
room just saying the r word
and so um i didn't say it you know so
don't get mad at me i'm [ __ ]
retelling it
or get mad at me whatever but that's
what he [ __ ] said he's dead now so um
cancel him like you did john wayne
remember when they tried to [ __ ]
cancel john wayne
yeah he's too white
all right pardon he's dead you know
um
so he did that and so what was i talking
about so i get to the break so he
[ __ ] poked it all up into my brain
and i thought what do you want to sing
to your word i thought about the singing
teacher thing you know
and uh
and it made me sneeze you know he did
both um
nostrils
and he pulled it out
and he was like
that's a train wreck
you know
he's just a train wreck up there
i was like so can you be
a little more specific like i have an
infection or what and he was like we
have an infection and you're not going
to not have an affection
unless we do unless we do surgery
and i was like huh and he says your
nasal passage
it goes like this
so what happens is
uh your body's trying to rid the fluid
and it's getting caught in this little
space here and it can't exit
where it's supposed to exit and it does
a liter a day so i'm like a liter is up
there and he's like it's not getting out
you gotta you gotta get surgery
so he's like let's do it in june so i
gotta do [ __ ] nose surgery dude oh
[ __ ] yeah man
[ __ ] yeah man gotta go under the knife
and he's gonna
you ever see that [ __ ] they just break
it
dude [ __ ] that i'm getting a nose job
too hell yeah dude i'm gonna come back
looking absolutely fantastic man you
think i got a big nose oh dude not now
not now i'm gonna have a [ __ ] that
cute slope that the chicks try to get
man i'm gonna get that cute slope like a
european titty or like a persian foot
dude it's gonna be so insane i'm gonna
look fantastic dude i'm gonna get that
european cute slope on the nose with the
[ __ ] chicks in the 80s in europe with
the sloppy tits or the [ __ ]
the persian feet dude
that elf [ __ ] dude forget it i'm gonna
have an elf foot on my nose dude and
it's gonna be small and dainty as [ __ ]
dude
people are gonna see me they go be like
yo dude you're very masculine but
between your eyes and mouth you're a hot
chick
and i'm gonna go thanks to the doctor he
said your nose is like a rorschach test
in there
i was like really is that [ __ ] up and
he was like yeah you're gonna have sinus
infections until we do this [ __ ] he gave
me some pills he said take two of these
every day for a week come back and we'll
reassess and then we'll set that surgery
date i already did the blood work baby
and did a sleep test did a sleep test
too your boy did a sleep test because i
thought i had sleep apnea because
kristen's always like hey you're snoring
and i go oh [ __ ] sorry dude i did a
sleep test guess what the dude said i
only had minor sleep apnea
[Music]
joke's on you baby
thought i was gonna have major sleep
apnea he said it's gonna be fine
so i have minor sleep apnea i don't have
to get a mask but i do need to get this
surgery with [ __ ] it which [ __ ] sucks
dude and so i'm gonna do the podcast
with the with the [ __ ] bandage on i
don't give a [ __ ] oh yeah you know for
clicks [ __ ] it uh not for clicks dude
i'm not one of those [ __ ] that do
[ __ ] for clicks right
but you know
i'll put the bandage on and i'll do the
podcast but i don't give a [ __ ] he was
like don't work out for two weeks though
when you get the surgery i was like all
right fine you know
i mean you know me dude i like to break
the strong guys hearts but okay
so now i got to get surgery bro i
[ __ ] got surgery one time and it was
on my knee because i did it i i [ __ ]
it up in jiu jitsu
man i was so i i just i tried to pass
somebody's guard and my knee just clicks
like this and one of the black belts
came over and he's like so what's up
your knees okay i was like no that hurts
it won't on click he's like so here's
what's going to happen um
so you've got a little bit of a a tear
uh you got to go you got to get surgery
doctor's going to come in it's going to
take about 10 minutes and uh it's going
to he's going to fix it and uh the
recovery times a few weeks and you're
gonna be fine and he just goes and walks
away and i was like okay
uh
i mean you know
i was so trying to ham up the [ __ ]
casualness of it that i was just like
this guy and he was [ __ ] right dude
i went and i did the knee surgery and i
was nervous because i had never been
under at all i'd never been i've never
been high in my life right even now and
he um he brought the [ __ ] uh the
what do you call it i was nervous about
just going to sleep during it
and they did it and they put me out they
told me count down from 100 i counted
down from 100 99
98 and i got to 97 and then i felt his
big hand he put his hand on my face like
you got it because i was a little
nervous he was like you got it and i was
like man he's got one hairy hand that
was the last thought i had and then i
fell asleep
and uh
and i actually tasted like what tasted
like an envelope thing
it tasted like i was licking an envelope
and then i passed out and then when i
woke up
i was like oh [ __ ] man that was uh all
right you're done already oh [ __ ] and i
was swearing and the nurse was like
jess can you she was like she was like
you're lucky the other nurse isn't here
she wouldn't have all that swearing and
i was i got so mad i was nice to know
that i got so mad even though i was high
i was like you're not going to tell me
what to do i just went through knee
surgery i was still me dude and i was
like same old me drugs don't change me
and then so um
so i i was like so i asked the doctor
later i was like i tasted like i was
licking an envelope
uh
when i was passing out i was like was
that actually the drugs that i was
tasting or was that in my mind because i
was high and he said oh it was in your
mind it was the drugs working on your
brain making you think you tasted it and
i was like wow and then kristen made me
get a [ __ ] i v drip two weeks ago and
he [ __ ] put the bag in it looks like
a bunch of piss
i mean it just literally looks like piss
like a bag of piss that he's [ __ ]
putting into my veins never done that
before and kristen likes to act like she
[ __ ] will do a an iv drip and it
saves her life
like chris will be like ah [ __ ] i have a
little headache i'm gonna do an iv drip
and it's gonna cure me and i'm like you
just you just you just waited and the
headache went away you know and she's
like no it really makes me feel
refreshed and i'm like dude that's such
a chick [ __ ] so i'm like i'm gonna do it
to prove to you that it ain't [ __ ] right
much like the last episode with the baja
bra
blast
so i did it he gave me a mega bag it
looked like it was pissing it and it
[ __ ] did it i i
i injected he injected all the [ __ ] the
big bag and i was like man i taste like
the [ __ ] envelope [ __ ]
and i was like am i tasting what's going
on and he's like oh yeah you can taste
it and i was like it's not my mind
playing tricks on me and he was like no
you can taste the drugs if they go
through and i was like dude my knee
doctor lied to me
so that's how i figured it out [ __ ]
15 years later do my my my my
arthroscopic
doctor whatever it's called
he lied to me dude he touched my face
with his hairy hand it was nice though
man i would go back to him
man when you pass out and [ __ ] wake
up it's like you just blinked right
can't wait to get my nose fixed
i'm gonna get a [ __ ] dope nose job
you know what [ __ ] that i'm gonna get a
bigger nose
i'm gonna get a can you make it black
that's what i'm gonna say
like black no like a black person knows
and wait to see how racist he is like
wider up gotcha
gotcha
gotcha
no i'm just saying like daryl strawberry
no you didn't mean that you meant that
okay
you wanna do my lips too what would they
be if you did my lips huh
racist i'm out of here
um
what about my ass would it be high up
okay dude yeah i know where you're
coming from
racist
in beverly hills beverly hills
that's where i want to go look at what
this [ __ ] kristen buys
no it's not even a pretzel it's broken
it's half a one she just got like a knot
this is a [ __ ] thing that has just
been here now bro
[ __ ] white women you know ooh
they look at [ __ ] and they go ooh
and then they just pay [ __ ] you know
35 dollars for it
oh
god creighton barrel is the most
place of all time
you go to cb2 forget it dude
by the way what happened to cb1 is that
still around creighton barrel why they
make a sequel to a place
[ __ ] off with that [ __ ]
what is that do you know what that is
yeah what it's like
oh it's like the cheaper one wow
all right well no you know it's just
make a different
i don't know how i feel about that but
it's just like
no
you know what i'm gonna do you know what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do [ __ ]
stand-up and then i'm gonna do a second
show in each city
not as good material and it's just gonna
be called [ __ ] don't push me too it's
going to be called crystallia 2. and i'm
just going to do [ __ ] hack [ __ ]
hey
so on the flight over here by the way
have you guys been to the airport what's
the deal walking around i mean come on
what's that smell it's like is there
even a bojangles in this airport
well have you seen crystalia too
you ever get the toilet paper on the
bottom of your heel and you walk around
like a true [ __ ] i mean come on
what the [ __ ] is my nose on the ground
no
why would i want tissue there
crystallia too i get bigger there doing
than my [ __ ] normal [ __ ]
so yeah dude chicks white chicks just
oh you know just a [ __ ] grasshopper
sitting sitting at a on a desk chair
like a [ __ ] that swivels just it's
this big huh that'd be cute
and you're just saying they bring it
home and you're just like oh [ __ ] my
mouth you know
so put this [ __ ] this is kind of cool
diddy's doing a [ __ ]
billboard music awards are on sunday and
a new interview host and executive
producer sean diddy combs explained why
the show will feature performances from
controversial figures morgan whalen and
travis scott
he says one of the things i'm doing
directly is uncanceling the cancelled
that's breaking news because people
haven't been about uncanceling but
canceling is a trend that needs to stop
that he told billboard he's scared for
his life you know travis went through a
tragedy morgan used the n-word while
talking to his boy people make mistakes
now we're moving on with love and
respect for everybody that was hurt or
affected it's time to forgive to have
morgan and travis be able to come back
and touch the stage again
with the mindset of getting a second
chance at life by the way dude morgan
wallin
uh does the biggest concerts dude he got
so much bigger for saying the n-word i
got to start doing i gotta start saying
that
just to people in cars
like him
i put up a crowdwork clip um crystal on
uh on my on this channel actually um you
can go look at it 22 minutes of just
stand up of just raw and uncut stand up
jams
if you want to watch the art of crowd
work
look it up it's a few videos down
raw
and uncut
comedy
dude um but yeah
and it's it's cool it's going doing
stupid numbers because your boy goes
dumb viral
i'm an infection
am i in my nose cause i'm dummy viral
um
oh son of my balls great dude when you
let me tell you something man chicks
don't know this when you sit on your
balls the world stops
it's literally like [ __ ] that scene
from saving private ryan when the guy's
looking for his arm on his his own arm
when it's like all [ __ ] quiet and the
grenade goes off and you just hear him
and the guy's looking for his uh when
you sit on your nuts that's how it is
dude
that [ __ ] buzz of the grenade
i had to go to the hospital once because
i [ __ ] sat on my nuts for real
we're telling truth today i guess i was
in high school i sat on my nuts i tried
to get into [ __ ] i tried to get into
uh
mrs kane's uh minivan and i sat on my
nuts and i went home and i was like mom
my bo i got to be honest with you my
balls really hurt and she was like what
i couldn't even [ __ ] stand up
straight went to the doctor and she put
jelly on my nuts and did an ultrasound
and she was like i think it's fine
you've got two
cords attached to your balls one goes
from your abdomen to your balls and the
other one is useless and it comes out
from under your balls and i was like
really it's like an appendix for your
balls and she was like yup and she was
like i think that's the one that twists
if that's the one that twists it really
hurts but it could have gone back if it
was the other one then we'd need to do
surgery and i'm just like jesus christ
man how did i not know this till now do
you know your balls can just twist and
then you got to get surgery like you
can't jiggle them out of place
if your balls twist you got to go in
there they got to cut your sack open and
untwist them imagine being the [ __ ] ass
that has to do that i don't mean the
doctor the guy who's got to go in for
the surgery dude
doc what's he in for oh yeah i sat on
his balls in a minivan
ah untwisting him yep
that job sucks i remember once i went i
did i used to get like
uh fissures in my uh this is well it's a
truth episode fissures in my anus you
know like [ __ ] uh
what do you call them not just fissures
but the uh
tear not the tears but the i would do
like i would wasn't drinking enough
water in my early 20s and i would take
dumps and it would like [ __ ] be just
like it would be like [ __ ] balrog's
head trying to come out
and um
hemorrhoids yeah
and so uh try to spell that word by the
way and i would go to the doctor and i
went one time i was like i i was like i
went twice because it was like just so
it hurts so much and then i went again
like a year later
and i was like hey and he's like so
what's the problem and i was like i i
i'm
my anus it hurts so bad and then he
literally rolled his eyes and i was like
okay this is the last time i'm coming in
i'll eat it from now on
and he just said he wrote a prescription
he was like yep there it is he looked in
my butt and he was like yep there it is
and wrote a prescription and i was like
i'll just prepare h it from now on dude
i'll [ __ ] diy my fissures
i'll i'll just [ __ ] wish back in my
hemorrhoids no worries
and yeah i said it i had hemorrhoids and
you know what they don't ever fully go
away and you know what i don't give a
[ __ ] you ain't [ __ ] if you haven't had
heteroids hemorrhoids i'm the man for
that dude
i'm the [ __ ] man for having about
four hemorrhoids and some fissures
you ever rip your aim anus and not
because you're gay just cause you have
shits
that's the man
that's the man
that's the man right there the man right
here
that's the man right there
that's the man right there
oh wait
oh my god those are matt's
glasses
he hasn't seen him in years i found
glasses
in my drawer and they're my brothers
yeah dude we solve crimes here
dude i've been watching the staircase
and that's all that's been on my mind
i'm like did he do it or not do it i
know i talked about the staircase and
there's a i did a freestyle on instagram
about the staircase it was very
important
bro greg kinnear would have nailed that
part
but um anyway
i watched the staircase and i'm like i
don't know if he did it or not but
here's the deal they didn't prove it
they didn't prove it you got to prove it
beyond a reasonable doubt there was too
much [ __ ] up and how about that [ __ ]
diva blood analyst dude the deva blood
analyst dude just lied for like a decade
there were 35 cases in durham north
carolina that this deever dude the blood
spatter analysis dude the science he
lied about the site he didn't lie about
the science but he didn't give all of
the tests he would just work with the
prosecution dude it's [ __ ] rigged bro
there were people there was somebody in
jail for 17 years and they realized that
he didn't [ __ ] put all the tests in
the evidence that he should have and the
guy didn't kill someone dude
17 years imagine being in jail for 17
years for some [ __ ] that you didn't do
and coming out and you gotta
not murder everybody
i'd be murdering people at chick-fil-a
for no [ __ ] reason dude
oh there's cheese in this
pap
pap i said no cheese pap pap oh no wait
i did say cheese huh already dead
sorry i was in jail for 17 years you get
if you're in jail for 17 years for
murder honestly and then you you get
exonerated and it turns out there was
evidence against you or with for you
that in your favor that they not only
that not only that they didn't find but
they knew about and didn't you should be
able to get to kill however many people
you were in [ __ ] jail for
oh i got one oh i get i get to okay so
that guy's got not only he missed 17
years out on life but now that guy's got
a good life cause now everyone has to be
nice to that [ __ ]
that's the rule i swear to god i'd be
fine with it and if he got me
on a bad day
all right [ __ ] i opened the door
for you you just said thank you but then
i tried to [ __ ] and he bap right in
my head i go oh [ __ ] and then he says
yeah but i was in jail for 17 years for
murder so when i didn't murder and i got
out i go like
that's on me dude that's how this
that's how this world works
catch me [ __ ] glug glugging out and
you get to kill him in any fat maybe you
just get to [ __ ] stick a bullet in
there brain that's it but dude i mean it
man
you go to jail for [ __ ] embezzling
money turns out you didn't do it you get
to [ __ ] take money from whatever
company
you want or whatever the [ __ ] it is you
know
the bp oil spill if they got off you
know what i mean or whatever it is
i don't even know if there was a
criminal investigation there or whatever
and then they didn't do it and they were
in jail and they get exonerated they get
to go in and just [ __ ] and [ __ ] put
oil wherever the [ __ ] they want dude on
an enemy's house
you know what i'm talking about so
everyone's extra nice you go to jail for
dude scariest thing ever ever is to go
to jail for some [ __ ] you didn't do to
just be an [ __ ] that was around
somebody that got killed you know what i
mean
jesus christ
you gotta be that guy in in jail that's
like what are you in here for
you gotta admit to it you gotta you
gotta say you did it
you gotta say you did it
you can't be the [ __ ] in jail that
didn't do the thing
[ __ ] that dude if i if i were to ever go
to because if i were to ever go to jail
like it would be because of some [ __ ]
speeding tickets or some [ __ ] that i had
unpaid for like way too long that i
didn't know about my license was expired
and [ __ ]
but dude
i would you get in there i would just
what are you in here for dude
i would i would act it so sir you heard
about the [ __ ]
the three families that died
in uh to look a lake no and it didn't
even happen but they wouldn't know
because they don't get the news you know
you don't have oh that's right you guys
don't have [ __ ] twitter in here um
yeah that was there was three families
i i uh i killed them all um execution
style
yep
and then i embezzled a bunch of money
you look like you could be in that
family
and then just spin away
you can't be like i didn't do it what
are you in here for uh something i
didn't do then you get [ __ ]
oh you want to get [ __ ]
but the thing about the staircase is
that guy went into 15 years of prison
and he was bi so he was probably having
the time of his life i mean [ __ ] wise
[ __ ] wise anus wise but dude like and
dickwise but not if like you're talking
about like
it's actually a bit [ __ ] up man if you
think about it to be like
i would always talk about i talk about
this like i would [ __ ] dudes if i was in
jail for sure no doubt no there's no it
would take eight days people like when
would you crack dude it'll be a little
over a week
i'd be like all right well i guess we're
doing this [ __ ] it
you think you're gonna what the [ __ ] you
know for life
everyone's getting [ __ ]
[ __ ] me too man it's like you know you
gotta try i don't know man
it is what it is you know it is you know
it is what it is that's me while i'm
getting railed from behind it is what it
is isn't it pinky or whatever the [ __ ]
you know people in prison have [ __ ]
names and [ __ ]
um
i would run that if i would run it
though seriously like my [ __ ] would be
[ __ ] unstoppable i would be the dude
with the gift of gab just [ __ ] on top
of the table in the cafeteria
and this is what they want us to think
and they're just like i don't even know
who he's talking about but i'm with this
[ __ ]
i gotta pee i'll be right back
yeah man
i uh i haven't really talked i talked a
little bit about the johnny depp case
i can't believe i never talked about how
amber heard it
[ __ ] in his bed
dude
like let me just
i don't what i don't understand is
how do you
write
an op-ed about how a guy is abusive
period
especially if it didn't happen
but period if if you've if one of the
skeletons in your closet is
you [ __ ] in someone's bed on purpose
it's gonna come out
how are you gonna sue someone
if you [ __ ] in their bed
scuna leak
okay
dude
amber heard admitted the poop in her
shared bed with johnny depp
was a horrible practical joke
a security guard testified
hey
put you know set up a tripwire
[ __ ]
light his shoelaces on fire
first of all when you [ __ ]
you don't know if it's going to be a
hard one or a loose one you know what i
mean like
talk about rolling the dice with your
anus
also
imagine her actually sitting there
i want to know how she did it like
squatting or like on her knees did she
[ __ ] on her feet a little bit or did she
just sit with her legs straight out
or did she [ __ ] and then put it in the
bed
i mean how are you gonna sue someone how
are you gonna try and sue someone
for damages
one [ __ ] in their bed also
when you [ __ ] in your bed when you [ __ ]
in your guys's bed
it's gonna leak
i mean it is insane that he was like
well she [ __ ] on my bed
and then she was like okay well that was
yeah i forgot that was
i'm sorry you're gonna sue me
i
i'm the one who
you did [ __ ] in my bed right
you did [ __ ] in my life [ __ ]
like i'm [ __ ] in my bed like jack
sparrow
just
order order order
was loose in our shared bed
with like [ __ ] what's his name uh in
the [ __ ] fear and loathing in las
vegas
hunter whatever the [ __ ]
um
defamation trial more like a defecation
trial
i mean someone must have made that joke
right if i was johnny depp that's the
thing about me bro if you ever get me on
the stand or anything like that as a
lawyer i've been watching these
[ __ ] of the staircase man i'd
be cracking jokes left and right dude i
would be winning cases purely from
charisma dude [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
the jury would be like you know what
maybe his client did it but i like this
guy and i i want to [ __ ] vote for him
i would end each [ __ ] clothing
closing statement with guys vote for me
defamation current defamation case
more like a defecation case
[Laughter]
yeah well this this case sure [ __ ] the
bed if you know what i mean
with a long cigarette
like [ __ ] what's his name
don res thompson [ __ ] you figured it out
figured it out
she [ __ ] on the bed
in the covers too dude
talk about a dutch [ __ ] yeah dude dutch
oven it you ever dutch oven it she
[ __ ] baked that [ __ ] she [ __ ]
dutch she regular ovened it
she she [ __ ] what do they call the
the one of those [ __ ] gr ovens the
the wolf ones the what are they called
i got one what is it
i don't know
she industrial size oven his [ __ ] bed
just plop the [ __ ] how do you know if
it's gonna be hard or loose dude also
why do you want to do the then you gotta
waddle over to the [ __ ] bathroom and
wipe it dude how weird is that case over
cut cut oh she she [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
bed cut cut case over
you win how much however how much you
want johnny
oh 50 million that's what you get dude
[ __ ] in your bed
the goal
only
a woman dude oh no
a white i'll say a white movie star
woman would do that [ __ ]
like well yeah i'll get i'll win
like to the the sociopathic behavior
dude
well it was a joke
unbelievable man
look at this [ __ ] from the insider
amber heard took responsibility for the
poop in her shared bed with johnny depp
that night after an explosive fight
yeah one else was explosive
we had an explosive fight and an
explosive anus didn't we
[Music]
sir take off those rose tinted glasses
please
but i was in the movie fear and loathing
in las vegas
[Laughter]
yeah we we know mr depp
objection he's acting like the character
the judge is like i'll allow it
turns out i like that movie i'll allow
it continue
can you do the scene in the car with
benicio del toro please
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] dude um
starling jenkins a member of depp
security team that's a [ __ ] hell of a
name for a security guard
starling jenkins protector
um
testified about the feces during the
during the trial between herd and depp
on thursday
wow feces you know
depp is suing her alleged she defamed
him when she describes we know about
that jenkins testified about the time
surrounding herd's 30th birthday she's
30.
and she did this [ __ ] literally april
31st 2016 def test write earlier on
trial that he was late to the party the
couple's shared los santos penthouse
apartment because he was having an
in-depth conversation with his business
manager about
the unexpectedly disastrous state of his
finances he alleged that after dinner
heard berated and hit him okay
as if that's not enough huh depp left
heard in the apartment when while he
went to his house in the hollywood hills
next morning after heard left on a
scheduled trip to coachella unreal dude
she [ __ ] in his bed and went to
coachella dude
a housekeeper found a fecal matter on
depth side of the couple's shared bed
my initial response to that was i
laughed depp testified earlier
describing the reaction to seeing a
photo of the feces
it was so outside it was so bizarre and
so grotesque that i could only laugh
i wasn't fearing nothing in las vegas
objection i'll allow it i like the movie
um
god
feces
and then heard
uh described it as a horrible practical
joke gone wrong
i mean what what would be going right
oh my god she's [ __ ] in my bed
[Laughter]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
amber heard
[Music]
[Applause]
um
i lived with those dogs johnny depp said
i pick up their funk it was not the dogs
while i saw johnny deputy say funk
did you funk in my bed
somebody funked in my bed
i'll allow it
[Laughter]
johnny watch it
that isn't how you did it in the movie
johnny
i'll allow it
um
wait a good time here on this
congratulations podcast and uh remember
i'm gonna be out there on tour get your
tickets boston's almost sold out so get
your uh boston tickets um and then uh
that's no that's in november but it's uh
about to sell out atlanta is about to
sell out too september ninth washington
dc
is on its way stockton california
oakland california peoria rockford
raleigh october 21st savannah georgia
denver colorado november 5th at the
bellco
um
cheyenne wyoming and jacksonville
florida so that's where i'll be and go
ahead and watch my uh my new crowd work
thing that i posted on this channel uh
just type in crowdwork crystalia
and uh and that's that
um there is a link below this video you
can check out my tour dates hey guys
that's it for the episode here on
youtube if you want the rest of the
episode the uncut
raw unedited episode on patreon go over
to patreon.comcrystalia
and check it out for only six dollars a
month you get a fruit you get that on
every episode you get the raw uncut and
you also get an extra episode a month
uh and right now i think there's 13
we've been doing it for 13 months so go
binge em dude go binge em like it's
you know boston legal or some [ __ ] uh so
patreon.com crystalia and um that's
where it is we also do other stuff too
go check it out man
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you